growing up my father is in the Navy and
he had actually visited Atlantic Canada
a few times he always told me how
special the place was hope our rocks in
New Brunswick have the highest tides in
the world it was amazing to see I made
sure that a local guide could show me
just how drastic the tide change
actually is today we have a little over
a 40 foot tide put on our best days we
get a 46-foot tide here at the whole
balrog there's nothing like seeing the
power of the ocean at work
I heard the seafood New Brunswick was
incredible so I went to Elma Lobster
shop to try some people come from
everywhere to try your lobster we have
the best lobsters in the world that they
funded Joe who's part of the family run
business even took time out of his day
to have lunch with me which is pretty
cool I headed to st. John after to meet
chef Jesse Bergen welcome to st. John
Batman thank you see John is actually
Canada's oldest incorporated city it's
kind of turning into this really vibrant
restaurant and bar scene yeah this is
really good but it still retains like
this old-world charm being in Atlantic
Canada I had to visit Fogo Island it's
this special untouched place with a rich
history incredible landscapes and warm
welcoming people if the lenders have a
gift of place you belong to the place
the place doesn't belong to you Zita
Cobb who founded the end just has this
amazing perspective on how to bring the
natural environment and people together
if you're a designer or an architect
your job is to find ways to hold hands
with the past and reach out to the
future place that kind of seems like
it's untouched from the world nature
knows everything every human being
should get up in the morning look at the
world and try to
as Oh
it's one of the more special places that
I've ever visited
[Music]